Adam the Apostate has a really
interesting post on X. He asked former
Muslims to share why they left Islam. I
want to read some of the responses for
three reasons. One, it's good to
understand the kinds of things that
bother Muslims about Islam and that
ultimately convince them to leave the
religion. Two, we should all be
supporting the ex-Muslims who are
responding. Whether you agree with their
reasons or not, whether you agree with
where they ended up or not, keep in mind
these are people who are under a death
sentence because they refuse to
mindlessly obey the ramblings of an
illiterate 7th century Arabian caravan
robber. Very frequently, their families
turn their backs on them. If a woman is
married and has kids and decides to
leave Islam, she's probably got a battle
ahead of her because her husband's
family is going to try to keep the kids
from her. There's always a huge cost for
leaving Islam and Muslim leaders want it
to stay that way because that's how they
keep people from leaving Islam.
Three, as new alliances are forming, as
for instance, Tucker Carlson and Candace
Owens fans become increasingly
pro-Islam, it's going to become more
popular for non-Muslims to condemn and
mock ex-Muslims.
Look at what Milo just said on X. When a
man leaves Islam, it is normally because
he is a homosexual choosing DA over
Dean. That's choosing the world over the
faith. When a woman does it, it is
because she craves the life of a
prostitute and because she has just been
tipped off that her Only Fans has made
it into the hands of her uncles.
You'll be seeing more of this as people
who want attention like Milo realize
that there's a really easy way to get
attention. Just say something stupid and
insane that Muslims agree with instant
clicks. So, weird times, but we've got
Adam the Apostate. He's an ex-Muslim and
an Oxford Theology graduate who posted,
"Ex-Muslims,
please comment below the reasons why you
left Islam to help spread awareness for
the liberals who have no idea what it is
like for people like us, if it is safe
and able for you to do so. Thank you to
all those on the ex community who stand
with and support us. And here are some
of the responses. Nura, I read the Quran
in English and was disgusted at the word
of God. turned to the Hadith and Sunna
and was even more disgusted when I
discovered the so-called prophet's life,
his wives, his morals, and his appetite
for war, plunder, and grape, which
basically make up the religion. Anna, I
left Islam because my ex-husband used
Islam to justify domestic abuse. Local
imams agreed. His family agreed. Police
got me and my kids to safety. I thought
I'd study more Quran because they must
have been wrong. My story is pinned on
my profile. Indeed, they must have been
wrong. There's no way the Quran says,
"Oh, wait. Here it is in surah 4:34.
Men are in charge of women because Allah
hath made the one of them to excel the
other and because they spend of their
property for the support of women. So
good women are the obedient, guarding in
secret that which Allah hath guarded. As
for those from whom ye fear rebellion,
admonish them, and banish them to beds
apart, and scourge them. Then if they
obey you, seek not a way against them.
Lo, Allah is ever high, exalted, great.
Brew note, I left Islam around 18 and am
now 49 and Christian for the past two
years. I was an atheist in between. Why
I left is not as important as what I
know to be true now. In my experience,
Islam is not based in love or presence
of God or the light. Music is forbidden.
People do not carry warmth and grace and
what I now know as real kindness. There
is a scary edgy robotic obedience that
in contrast to what I know now is
absolutely not of a divine creator. When
your needs are challenged by someone who
thinks like this, you do not matter.
That is a big problem. I have a longer
post explaining my life story pinned to
my profile and I am happy to answer
anyone's questions
on the blockchain. the inequality of the
sexes, the general tribal mindset of
hating non-Muslims. It's so normalized
to demonize non-Muslims that many
Muslims don't know the rest of the world
isn't like that or at least the West
strives to be better than that mindset.
Muhammad's character, for obvious
reasons, the support for enslaving
non-Muslims, there are so many, but this
was the reason I left Islam. Bosch, I
left Islam in my mid- teens because of
the fundamental dishonesty of all of the
Muslims around me. They lied in big ways
and small as if the truth didn't matter
at all. Ex-Muslim shake, I left Islam
because I got tired of pretending that a
book advocating wife beating, slavery,
and killing apostates is holy and
peaceful. Mediah, I left because I read
Quran, found human rights and especially
women's rights issues.
One, zero proof that it's true religion.
Two, morals. As gay men, I would never
be part of religion that thinks I should
be killed for being gay. Three, women's
rights. A religion that treats women as
slaves and says it's okay to grape her
doesn't deserve to be followed. In
Islam's defense on the gay issue, there
was the night of Alz. I left because the
Quran confirms marriage with minors and
scientific mistakes and moral problems.
Scientific mistakes. You think the sun
setting in a muddy pool and stars being
missiles that Allah uses to shoot demons
and semen forming between the backbone
and the ribs are scientific mistakes.
Maybe science just hasn't caught up to
the Quran yet. I left when I found that
it is okay to marry minors according to
Islam.
Impossible. Let's refute this right now.
Sah Bkari 5133.
What's the chapter heading? Giving one's
young children in marriage is
permissible. Uh-oh. Why? By virtue of
the statement of Allah. And for those
who have no monthly courses, i.e. they
are still immature. Surah 65:4 of the
Quran which allows marriage to
prepubescent girls. And the ida, the ida
is the waiting period for a woman or a
girl after her husband divorces her. She
has to wait a certain amount of time
before she can marry another man. And
the ida for the girl before puberty is 3
months in the above verse. So if a man
divorces a preubescent girl, how long
does the prepubescent girl have to wait
before the next guy marries her? 3
months. And to illustrate Allah's ruling
about marriage to prepubescent girls in
the Quran, Bkari quotes Aisha saying
that Muhammad had sex with her when she
was only 9 years old. Narrated Aisha
that the prophet wrote the marriage
contract with her when she was 6 years
old and he consummated his marriage when
she was 9 years old and then she
remained with him for 9 years i.e. till
his death. Wow, these ex-Muslims are
right. I was never a true Muslim. I was
forced to learn and pray in Turkey.
While being forced to learn and pray, I
learned that it is all about death and
destruction. It is a cult worshiping
death. True, true. Total death cult. I
am ex-Muslim because I believe Islam is
a cheap copying of the other religions,
just more harsh, fake, and brutal. You
should live with them to see the degree
of barbarism.
I left because my ex-husband used the
religion to imprison me. I decided one
day to step outside of Islam and look in
rather than staying within the fold of
Islam and looking out as I had been want
to do for about four decades. It was
difficult but I had to do it. I realized
I had been blind. I started to research
and hear what non-Muslim scholars also
had to say. Those who were more willing
to ask the tough questions. I eventually
came to the realization that Islam is
Arab propaganda. I had systematically
dismantled my own identity. It was
painful to be honest, but I feel free
after leaving Islam and religion in
general. The irony in all this is that
my belief in God has never been
stronger. The only difference is that
I've turned my back on the Arab God.
When I was a young kid, I realized how
evil Islam is based on the ideas I
always saw. None of it made sense to me
as a child. I would try to tell people
how bad it is, and they would attack me.
30 years later, the same Islam
slaughtered our people in Iran. Now,
everyone understands.
I was one of those liberals that
converted. And let me tell you, 12 years
later, I escaped with my children. Islam
is like the mob. It's not designed for
leaving, especially for women. Because I
am considered half a man in Islam.
Because I have a male legal guardian who
decides whether I can get a job, a
passport, or even an education. Because
I was forced into hijab at age six.
Because I was told over and over again I
am responsible for the honor of the
family. Because I was sexually assaulted
at age 11, but I was told I was
responsible for all men's sexual
desires. Because I inherit half my
brother because my witness in court is
half. Because my father, brother, uncle,
grandfather, any man in the family could
kill me to restore the honor of the
family if they feared my rebellion and
dishonoring the family name and would
never be punished. Because I am worth
half a man if I get killed. Because I
was told my whole life I was going to
burn in hell for my hair showing and my
improper hijab. Because I knew if my
husband wanted to have a second or third
or fourth wife, I could not object.
Because he could divorce me whenever he
pleased and take my children if I ever
gave birth. Because he could beat me
black and blue and I still couldn't get
a divorce. because I was tired of not
being human enough for Islam to be
afforded dignity and safety and
autonomy. #Islamot trauma
grew up in Iran. All they told us was to
hate. Death was the only guaranteed way
to heaven. As an Indian Muslim, Allah's
hatred for polytheists and his sherk
obsession made zero sense. I left
because of violence in Islam and life of
prophet Muhammad. I left Islam because
concept of God seemed illogical to me. I
left Islam about 1.5 years ago. The
Sufism my father taught me was a good
moral code and guide through my life.
But I look around and see so few people
taking the Quran seriously and claiming
to follow the faith. I can see a
dangerous rot spreading in the UK. It
violates core principles of the Quran
and is very dangerous to the culture.
Kind of odd. He left Islam but thinks
the problem is people who aren't
following the Quran properly.
Goofy Sufis. I left Islam because it is
a religion of murderers and pedos.
I had some questions about status of
women and at the time I realized I was
always in denial about true status of
non-Muslims in Islam. I couldn't find
any satisfactory answers. So I started
rereading Quran and hadiths. That was
that. I left Islam because I am a
Persian woman. I think this should
explain everything. I left because it's
a toxic ideology that stands against
girls and women, freedom, critical
thinking, personal choice, and overall
human rights. I'm a child marriage
survivor because of Islam. Many won't
want to hear it, but it's my lived
truth. You're free to speak yours, and
I'm free to speak mine. I left Islam in
2016 because there are 20 different
Arabic Qurans with thousands of
contradictory variants. Come on, there's
only one Quran. If you think there are
more, let's see them.
>> NOW, HOLD THESE UP. AND WHAT DO WE NOW
KNOW about these Qurans?
>> Says there's nothing. NOW, DO ALL THESE
QURANS AGREE WITH EACH OTHER?
>> NO.
ARE THERE TWO QURANS that agree with
EACH OTHER?
>> NO.
>> I apologize. You were right. I was
wrong. There are tons of different
Qurans.
I left Islam after reading Quran and
Hadith with meaning. I was Muslim for 40
years. For me, it was the rise of
normalized hatred after October 7th.
Watching the manipulations and lies
gather support was disgraceful. The
internet played a big part in me finally
seeing Islam for what it truly is. Also
was born and raised Muslim because very
disillusioned with the behavior and
hypocrisy of other Muslims excusing
their sin met a Christian who discussed
his and my faith came away realizing
Islam is demonstrably false, dark and
unfortunately evil. became a Christian
months later
because of the war bounties and
concubines. When I read it for the first
time, I was astonished that how come
it's even morally justified.
Ex-Muslim from Maldes here. Islam is
forced on all the citizens of Maldes and
nobody is allowed to criticize it. Phase
three of Islam. I left Islam after
reading the Quran and Hadiths multiple
times because it's illogical, immoral,
and violent. I left Islam once I read
the Quran. I was born in a Muslim
family. As a woman, it didn't make
sense. It still doesn't make sense.
Moreover, their God is really sadistic,
keeping track of how much you pray in
order to reward you in afterlife.
and Canadian ex-Muslim says, "Read my
bio." Okay, we will. Allah allows sex
slavery, child marriage, and wife
beating. He commands Muslims to hate
Christians and Jews and kill
non-Muslims. That's why I left Islam.
I'd say these ex-Muslims have a point.
Islam is indeed a huge steaming pile of
demonic nonsense. And that's why it has
to threaten people with death and all
sorts of other punishments to keep them
from leaving.
It's also why we need to support the
ex-Muslim community. One of Islam's most
powerful weapons is the fear of losing
family and friends, the fear of being a
disappointment to parents, the fear of
being ostracized and having nowhere to
go. There has to be a strong ex-Muslim
community so that people who want to
leave Islam can know that even if their
family abandons them, they've got
another family ready to help. This idea
has been part of Christianity from the
beginning because people in the first
century often had to give up a lot to
follow Christ. So Jesus said, "Truly I
say to you, there is no one who has left
house or brothers or sisters or mother
or father or children or lands for my
sake and for the gospel who will not
receive a hundfold now in this time
houses and brothers and sisters and
mothers and children and lands with
persecutions
and in the age to come eternal life. But
many who are first will be last and the
last first.
What does he mean when he says that if
you give up house or brothers or sisters
or mother or father or children or lands
for his sake, you'll get much more now
in this time.
Well, you may lose your family, but
you're becoming part of a much bigger
family, and your new family will take
care of you.
I put the link to Adam the Apostate's
post in the description. I would
encourage you to like and share some of
the responses and to follow some of the
ex-Muslims there. We want the ex-Muslim
community to grow because the bigger and
stronger that community gets,
the safer it will be for Muslims to stop
believing in the most obvious false
prophet in history.
You pride on that. You pride on that.
You just backfire
on me. This is a powerful religion.
There's a reason to it. Yeah. Yeah.
Here.